- Ils sont étudiants, ingénieurs
et informaticiens.
La plupart n'ont jamais touché
à un pistolet de leur vie.
Inspirés par la résistance
ukrainienne, alarmés
par la menace constante
d'invasion chinoise...
ils ont choisi de passer leur
samedi à apprendre les rudiments
du maniement d'armes.
Welly Huang, un ingénieur,
le fait pour lui-même,
mais surtout, pour sa famille.
Dans un sondage effectué
au mois de mai, plus de 60 %
des Tawawawanais disaient être
prêts à prendre les armes pour
défendre l'île contre la Chine.
Wang Ying-Jie ne veut pas avoir
à le faire, mais elle n'hésitera
pas si c'est nécessaire.
Ce cours de base la rend déjà
plus confiante es s s capacités.
Des cours plus poussés
de guérilla urbaine sont
même offerts.
La Chine compte 10 fois plus
de soldats que Taïwan et quatre
fois plus d'avions de chasse.
Mais pour beaucoup de Taïwanais,
la guerre en Ukraine prouve
qu'ils pourraient résister
eux aussi.
Les élèves tentent d'appliquer
les leçons de l'expérience
ukrainienne.
"La meilleure défense, c'est
l'attaque", dit cet employé
en marketing qu'on appelle
"prof Yeh" lors de cette
formation. "Pour se protéger,
il faut freiner et anéantir
l'ennemi", ajoute-t-il.
Les Taïwanais se bousculent
pour l'accès aux formations
de maniement d'armes de toutes
sortes.
Les inscriptions ont quadruplé
depuis le début de la guerre
en Ukraine, qui exacerbe
le sentiment de crise à Taïwan.
La formation pour les premiers
soins en temps de guerre
est aussi très prisée.
Des ateliers comme celui-ci
ont lieu chaque fin de semaine.
Dans ces cours pratiques
de quelques heures offerts
chaque samedi cet été,
les participants apprennent à
arrêter un saignement abondant.
On leur enseigne aussi
quelques techniques d'évacuation
rapide des blessés.
"Si la Chine nous attaque,
il y abebebeaucoup de blessés,
croit Jo Yi Shao. Je veux
pouvoir faire ma part."
"Je me sens un peu plus brave
après ce cours", ajoute-el
Enoch Wu est à l'origine
de ces formations populaires.
Selon lui, ça témoigne de
la solidarité des Taïwanais
et de leur désir de protéger
leur démocratie.
La menace d'invasion chinoise
fait partie du quotidien
à Taïwan depuis longtemps.
Les craintes et inquiétudes
sont omniprésentes.
Même si les tensions
avec la Chine sont vives,
Welly Huang ne croit pas
à une attaque imminente.
isisis elle viendra, dit-il.
Dans un an, dans cinq ans.
Peu importe."
e e e tant de Taïwanais,
il jure qu'il sera prê